you don't know which officer is going to
show up you don't know how they're going
to react you don't know how the script
works the script does not exist and for
a lot of people and that's where the
problem is it's a dice roll a lot of
time
it's just one of those moments where
like your mind just starts like racing
how like what road is this gonna go down
I feel like at this point you just like
never really know my parents I forget
what they were doing but I was standing
outside I was 7 or 8 and I saw the
police beat up a man I remember not
asking my parents about it because I had
the very sort of visceral sense that
this was just how things were
[Music]
I think of all the other people who are
doing nothing wrong and still guy in the
situation
it's just a fear of knowing that I can
do a million things that would seem
harmless to me or anybody else
and that it could end my life
[Music]
and you just look around and realize
that the playing field is not level I
don't I struggle with whether it's even
fair or ethical to bring a black child
into this world with things being the
way that they are
it's a gamble to live in general but I
think there's a big difference between
chance things that can happen and then
there that there is people out here who
will target your child you know they
might be part of this ongoing theater of
violence without the gun without
repercussion I don't know if I have that
in me I can't recall a certain moment
where I was like oh you know now this
happened and so now as a result like I'm
scared I think just probably witnessing
things over time and I don't think these
are necessarily new things but with
technology we just see them a lot more
instantly and it's definitely
intensified
I love to walk late at night and well
I'd like to think that I present as
pretty unassuming and non-threatening
there's always a chance that someone
could not see me that way
stay safe but also like don't let it
like change who you are I don't want
them to make us be afraid to love and to
have families all cops need to play by
the same rules and those rules need to
be that everyone is treated equally
that's what's at the core of all of this
you